hi my name is victor baldus and today
i'm going to teach you how to create
proper margins for your design when you
write a letter you don't start on the
outer edge of the paper the same applies
for placing columns on an artboard to
make your text legible and pleasing for
the eye you need to add white space
around your columns we call these
margins but how much margin do you add
to a book
to a business card a flyer there is no
standard way to do this but there are
some methods we can use like the thumb
margin system where the margin should be
at least a thumb wide to not obscure any
text or images this works great for
books mobile phones and other devices
another way to create margins that are
pleasing to the eye is to create a set
of diagonal lines like this
and then there's a type system where you
create a system of margins based on the
size of the type you are using the goal
of creating margins is to create a
layout where text and images has room to
breathe and ultimately create a solid
hierarchy in your design if you want to
learn more about margins design systems
and grids i've created the grids and
layouts kit where i outline the process
to create beautiful layouts i've also
included templates with the most common
grids so you can create them with ease